we're back again No
hey I'm in every smell beef did oh no no
you know your life is different now I'm
yours memory work this old song and
dance with consent all I can say alcohol
like two weeks ago I tweeted out asking
you guys to send mamrie and I some of
your best and worst Halloween costumes
for us to comment and review and you
guys sent so many they were so
ridiculous and I haven't looked at the
screen grabs like since we wanted to
make sure that this didn't fall under
the cracks or fall through the cracks we
wanted to my crack the cracks
we wanted to indirectly roast your
Halloween costume I mean you guys
roasted yourselves you dressed up like
this already
and we're gonna do a bunch of them here
on this channel and then we're gonna do
a bunch of them over on mamie's channel
so when you're done watching this video
make sure you go over to Bieber's
channel to see the rest of them because
they're I mean it's just a symphony of
the funk and Zuma Xena I've never looked
better
I don't even know what this is I think
we should Google is this an anime
character Oh Emperor's New Groove
I thought she was like just a very cold
beans I thought they were too weird
outlets but like I still love this you
nailed it
you guys all look fantastic and no one's
wearing a wig you guys are great I would
do that every year where are you guys
they're in someone's mom's house who
loves quilted I taped all my friends
Facebook engagements and marriages to
myself and went as forever alone that's
one way to get sympathy
no genie and magic carpet from Aladdin
that's adorable and you're in Disney
it's incredible oh I guess the carpet is
a real good costume when you're like on
the first day of your period you get the
green light to fall asleep anyway that's
what I'm screaming raggedy and and
hippie we have to be in fourth or fifth
grade Raggedy Ann is slightly right I
dressed my boyfriend up as my PSL one
year I like that she added a caution hot
thing that gives him a little ego boost
and the confidence oh and the cargo
shorts are the cardboard sleeve that's
real cute that is cute you guys are cute
and I love that you took this photo at a
gas station oh my god tried to beat Ozzy
Osbourne in eighth grade when they got a
bat we're gonna eat the head off about
in eighth grade now is the time this is
me as Mona Lisa in fifth grade we have
an artful kid whose decision was this do
you see the construction of this oh my
god it looks amazing
happy Halloween from angry Arthur and
the dancing pumpkin man
I know the dancing pumpkin man I don't
know angry Arthur Oh Oh Arthur the
aardvark from my John Legend hmm Wow
guys thank you so much for confessing
all of your Halloween sins to us and
also you know some of your higher
moments well thank you for watching this
video I hope it was fun for you it was
fun for us and happy Halloween to
everyone out there if you hadn't
listened to this week's episode and this
make it weird our podcast that comes out
every Wednesday
yeah you should because it was all you
know relatively Halloween themed it was
great we went and did a photo shoot at
JC Penney's and whole goth characters
which was an experience we talked about
on the podcast but also we have a
patreon patreon slash let's make it
weird that has all kinds of fun bonus
stuff you should check out as well all
the links are in the description box
below other than that I don't know whoa
no so I love it here in character I was
very much the kid that whatever my
costume was like I wasn't full character
when I said trick-or-treat oh yeah yeah
like this fine like we're gonna be a
trash bag in the yard come I may just
attract men full erect leaves right